well I said when I did my scary list the
next one I was gonna do was gonna be my
list of the funniest episodes of New Era
Doctor Who so yeah this one is gonna be
even more subjective than the scary one
was and this list was actually also
harder to get to so I a little bit of
guidelines on this I'm not talking about
funniest moments I'm not talking about
funniest scenes I'm not even talking
about funniest characters I'm talking
about APIs ODEs where there is an
important key element in the story which
is pervasive and across the episode
we're a big part of that is intended to
make you laugh maybe that's confined to
a character maybe it's combined to a
subplot or a B plot that's going on
maybe it's even the main plot is
intended to be funny it does not mean
that the entire episode maybe will get
classified as a comedy but there has to
be a important pervasive comedic element
running through the episode that's what
it'll get it qualified on here and this
list is yeah this was tricky to come up
with and there's some odd entries on
here we'll just get right to it
number 10 the unicorn and the wasp now
this is an episode that basically is on
here because of doctor and Donna banter
because I mean first of all the two of
them together have a wonderful banter
it's a big part of why Donna is my
favorite companion but then you add in
Donna's excitement in being the 1920s
the way she is you know trying to be as
modern a woman as she can get away with
in this setting the whole mystery aspect
and and it gets it gets campy in a way
that is kind of fun and kind of funny
and with how much the mystery of Agatha
Christie stories enters into their life
and Donna's like really this is this is
happening it's not the top level of
comedy that the show achieves but it's a
good thread throughout the episode
number nine the husbands of River Song
this is one that I probably think better
of now because I having had nardole for
series 10 where I liked it much better
than here I now sort of look at him his
appearance here more fondly so that
but beyond that just that sort of
flipping the dynamic on its head with
River and having her not even
recognizing the doctor at all and sort
of what that does to his ego a little
bit and then him him trying to him
dropping crazy obvious instant trying to
get her to understand she just she
doesn't even notice him and the the
villain is fairly comedic in this
comedic Villas the doctor who can be a
little bit if he like max Capricorn
doesn't work for me at all here it works
I think well enough because they don't
give us too much of him with hydroflax
I'm talking about
and they sideline him well if and
everyone else seems to understand what a
ridiculous caricature of a tyrant this
guy is so it just works they they
balance did it he could have gone bad
but I think they balanced it just right
for some good laughs number eight
dinosaurs on a spaceship I know this is
not a particularly well regarded episode
but I have a lot of fun with this
episode and it's funny fun the big-game
hunter in the egyptian queen Rory's
father is a great source of some
wonderful bits of comedy throughout this
episode and I just love the Glee of the
doctor when dinosaurs on a spaceship and
then of course there's the robots
I love these robots I I mean I'm a big
Douglas Adams fan so maybe it's a
holdover from loving Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy but I love sort of weird
bantery
kind of dumb robots that like they're
doing a function but they're just they
have this personality it's like why why
was that thing even programmed with that
but I love that kind of stuff and I
think it's played well here and I I do
actually enjoy it totally overall the
episode is a little weird but when it's
going for laughs I think it works very
well number seven the lodger
yes I do actually think that the comedy
works in here is the comedy too much of
a percentage of the episode possibly but
I still think it works I think the
doctor trying to be normal is funny I
think this guy who feels like he's the
only one who notices how weird this guy
is is kind of funny I think
I think the scene where the darkling
keeps banging his head into Craig's to
sort of fast-track information and do me
I love that I think that's really really
funny and I think that the dynamic
between the doctor and Craig is a big
part of why this works because again as
with so many things if the chemistry
fell flat the episode would not have
been funny it would have been painful
but I think that the comedy and this one
works even though maybe it leaned on
comedy a bit more than it should have in
terms of when it actually tries to pay
off a story at the end number six
partners in crime here we go again
doctor and Donna chemistry it counts for
a lot and Catherine Tate is great at
this kind of stuff the I mean at this
point the pantomime pit between the two
of them you know on opposite sides of a
room looking at each other through
windows I mean that's I mean that's just
classic at this point and it gets sort
of weirdly romantic comedy esque with
them like almost crossing each other's
paths over and over again but just
missing each other and often times with
these quote-unquote funny episodes that
I'm putting on here things get you know
serious later on and the comedy kind of
falls off and it doesn't really with
this one I mean you've got Donna going
I'm waving it fat and is it ridiculous
bull yeah but it's also pretty funny
number five the Sontaran stratagem in
the poisoned sky and yeah again dr.
Donna that's a big part of it but also
the Sontarans I think this was where
they got the balance of the inherent
comedy of the Sontarans just right in
terms of the doctor making fun of their
height a little bit obviously but also
sort of making fun of the guys name you
know when he's when he finds out part of
his title is the undefeateds like
whatever happens if you do get defeated
what are you gonna do to your name that
I mean like that's wonderful and funny
and also Donna you know proofing her
usefulness here not just you know taking
a shoe and hitting one of the Sun turns
in the back end the neck but also you
know knowing to look at the HR and stuff
at the factory go oh look at this no
sick days and her cockiness takes it
from her just being helpful to it
actually being funny because
way she delivers that in her very
pleased with herself manner Wow probably
most people wouldn't classify this as a
flat-out comedy I do think the comedic
elements are pretty consistent
throughout this entire story and for me
they work really well
number four robot of Sherwood there's
two main things that happen on this list
first of all I like the doctor kind of
being spiteful and bitter and being like
are you kidding me when he's dealing
with Robin Hood when the guy appears to
be as sincere as the legends would have
it be and the doctor can't even deal
with the fact that he's even there and
the two of them trying to one-up each
other I love that but ultimately this
thing won my heart immediately with one
simple line I'm the doctor and this is
my spoon yes every bit yes and that sets
the tone for the entire episode with how
wonderfully gloriously cheesy it is and
the doctor's frustration with that at
every step I just I think that really
works wonders in terms of an overall
dynamic and it makes this episode just a
lot of fun number three doctor's wife
now this is an episode with a lot going
on tonally it has melancholy aspects
horrific aspects there's a lot going on
but for me consistently the chemistry
between Matt Smith as the doctor and
this embodiment of the TARDIS in this
woman is funny watching them talk and
get to talk flat out like that and for
the first time his the ways in which she
surprises him and just some of her lines
are great in it of themselves it's all
wonderful stuff but really it is it is
the way that they talk to each other and
just especially when they start arguing
at a few points and it's just it's this
wonderful well-worn you're really
knowing each other couple that for
whatever reason haven't gotten to speak
before and they they get they get to
vent in both the most wonderful and the
most frustrating ways in terms of the
relationship between each other and it
makes me smile whenever the two of them
are on-screen together and I think it's
really funny number two
school reunion
again it's not a primarily funny episode
but there's a lot of funny stuff going
on in here enough that I think I'm more
than qualified so you've got rose and
Sarah Jane bickering over the doctor
you've got them laughing their butts off
when he walks in and he's just
frustrated cuz he's like why are you
laughing and you've got you've got k9
who is wonderfully perfectly cheesy and
funny cuz he's got that just slight dry
wit about him and Mickey realizing that
he's the tin dog is both funny and kind
of sad heck just the doctor pretending
to be a teacher in saying lines like
exactamundo a word I have never said
before and never will again it's got
wonderful moments like that sprinkled
throughout the entire thing and even the
villains have some nice ones because
you've got anthony Stewart hedges with
frustration forgets the shooty dog thing
and there's just the terrific sense of
reunion between the characters and the
way that they are bouncing off each
other throughout the episode is fun and
funny now my choice for the number one
funniest new era Doctor Who episode is I
suspect not gonna be one that people are
expecting but humour is incredibly
subjective and this happened to tap into
another one of my fandoms and handle it
very well in a very humorous way and as
a result I think it's really funny and
that is the return of Doctor Mysterio
yeah because I love Doctor Who I also
love superheroes I love Superman I think
Superman is great but Superman has not
been done well in a while and there's
something wonderful yet frustrating
about watching a show basically do a
parody of Superman and have that parody
exists as a better Superman than the
Superman that's currently in movies
these days but it just shows a really
great understanding of this comic book
universe and comic book conflict and
comic book characters in the way
superheroes work it is knowing enough to
be able to both subvert and play with
the tropes at hand
and not just be like yeah that's the
thing they do isn't it no it understands
why these things are done why they're
important why some of them are silly why
some of them really still need to be
there even though they are silly
this also gave us the reintroduction of
nardole who I really like and I think
he's a funny presence and I love the way
the doctor you know winds up this guy
trying to get him to reveal to to this
woman that he's in love with his secret
but he's just he just won't do it he's
using his powers to completely force the
force himself to not have to do it I
think this is a wonderful light-hearted
knowing send up and love letter to
superheroes as a whole and in a show
that didn't have to do something like
that and I think it doctor who did it
well I think you did it funny and it's
my pick for the number one funniest
episode of new who what are your
thoughts on all this
what's your list whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter a
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I am also one half
of the punch like a girl podcast that is
a presentation of the fire and water
podcast network fire and water
podcast.com until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]